hi guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan separate
tonight we're gonna check out this
trailer for a game called homefront
revolution mm-hmm inspired by the matrix
part three Matrix Revolutions if I am if
I am not mistaken damn no no no no
nothing it is the sequel to homefront
from my understanding you actually found
one game but I don't know a whole lot
about yeah Oh homefront that movie with
Jason Statham and James Franco
there's written by Sylvester Stallone
did different homefront I don't anything
about this game then yeah oh right Oh
bright baby 18 no I did not
sex sex dan
I don't think it's home front condom
edition Messick come up with that fist
that looks like Stanley Tucci
soldier Oh totally wrong Oh
how much why wake up America there we go
the [ __ ] is going on you should have saw
this coming oh yes oh he's back he's
gonna wake up America now what RPGs in
the face wakes everybody else
why would she get a play as like the
rebels yes that's the idea
what a cool character to be that's like
it's like a engine that is like putting
you in a movie you know I've always I've
never actually played a game like that
word the law enforcement is the villain
there's a couple as I say that not
thinking of it all last of US military
it was kind of a villain the homefront
one of the big points of that franchise
is that America has been taken over by
another country so the first one was you
trying to fight fight back and resist
them and then this is with the scenario
that they won and arm our only chance
now is to rebel I believe so
problem is is that the last one was
called very much a Call of Duty clone
much like hmm every other shooter out
there but it looks pretty cool be really
interested to see what they kind of do
with it but right now I like a story of
it you know it's a cool world to put a
gamer into mm-hmm to be able to just you
know live vicariously as that lead rebel
who doesn't want to be the lead rebel in
a movie like that come on [ __ ] John
Connor or the story everyone has that
dream of fighting the man yeah we grow
up we grow up fighting the man to me the
leader of that [ __ ] it's awesome it's
[ __ ] cool well thanks guys for
telling me about this trailer if you're
new to the channel and you kind of liked
what you saw or you loved it or you're
kind of whatever about it but you know
maybe subscribe okay we're going for
maybes on this one mainly so like click
on the subscribe button but don't let go
for a while yeah question yourself watch
do you really want to see us every week
think about it think about it and then
realize the answer is yes and then yeah
you know subscribe know there's
also you may check out getting your
goddamn job you can check out my demo
right here at the bottom that's a
betrayal I play games it's a gamer I
love playing games yes so I think
hopefully by the time this comes out my
unfair Sonic playthrough will be there
so if you like seeing angry people check
it out check it out so while uh Ryan
fixes the light I just thought I'd
mention in a previous episode I talked
about a game about passports being
boring and totally forgot about papers
please 2013 indie hit so yeah my bad
that games kind of awesome
Newlands soon I'm giving a shout out
right now haha dude the same way I feel
about this trailer I don't know what
he's talking about but asking for a
shout-out here for the natives down in
the Ghia River Reservation Arizona hmm
spreading the word to subscribed you got
some native fans guys that's awesome
that's pretty cool that's really cool
that's great we got some pilgrims on our
side now nope nope that's in karate sure
that's what natives are or just gonna
say Native Americans you know the people
that were here before you know we got
here pilgrims I appreciate you but I
still like you despite whatever kind of
you know Indian Reservation you come
from shout out shout out Joseph gurram
Oh Ryan can I get a shoutout please i
watch your videos every day you guys are
awesome yes I know something I don't
know I try to keep his ego Jack it
doesn't work it doesn't matter what he
tries yeah cuz my ego is it's huge huge
ego it's surprising that it can fit on
this couch with me mm-hmm-hmm tell you
man it's it's big sometimes you start
floating that's a baby ego is I've seen
it happen and it's really frightening at
first but then oddly calming at the same
I find the response to be rather they
are impressed because you know it's like
you gotta give the guy credit yeah I got
a lot of ego yeah and the fact that
you're levitating is also a feat that uh
yeah a lot of people haven't done you ya
know
only only pilgrim something your ego
hyper mentality yeah
you mean sha just discover your awesome
channel well hyper mentality how hyper
are you prove it to me write me the
longest comment I have ever read and I
will respond back with a thumbs up no
he's reading that whole damn thing and
he's going to give a bulb type ran up
response you've you if you write me the
longest comment ever hyper mentality
only you
I'm not asking all you guys and I will
give you a detailed response back if
you're gonna give him work you have to
have work you have to give work back
that's true that's true
mmm-hmm well hyper mentality let's see
how fast those fingers can type these
fingers inside pretty fast too and it
comes in handy you know what I mean
fingering I figured what that's like
I'm sorry I was writing on my Mel Gibson
impression let's get pizza let's do a
pizza party